dude if there was ever a [ __ ] reason
like uh we know here at congratulations
if you're part of this cult and if you
[ __ ] understand that one day we will
be in a log cabin if we wander we'll be
in a in the high grass sharing ideas uh
that we're not you know we try to limit
the [ __ ] - it as much as we can but
these gender reveal things are getting
out of control
okay somebody [ __ ] died because there
was a gender-reveal explosion
okay somebody died because there was a
gender reveal let's read about this will
reveal explosion oh my god
this look at this explosion at
gender-reveal party kills woman
officials say it's always officials say
family members at the party were
expectant parents where expectant
parents were announcing the sex of their
baby in a Verna created a pipe bomb I
mean Jesus that killed a woman in Iowa
Jesus I mean a woman in Iowa died during
a gender-reveal announcement on Saturday
after flying debris from an explosion
from what amounted to a homemade pipe
bomb struck her Jesus the woman died
instantly after she was struck in the
head by a piece of metal from a device
that was intended
Jesus man this article's brutal was I
mean was it a boy or a girl - at least
tell us oh my god a hole had been
drilled in the side for a fuse a piece
of wood was placed on top of gunpowder
Oh bad idea and colored powder was
placed on top of the board tape was in
wrapped over the top of the middle metal
tubing inadvertently creating a pipe
bomb
I mean 45 feet from the device
that struck her continued 144 yards
farther through the air and landed in a
field oh man you know what man that's so
sad
God oh there's another one here in
Australia a car that begins slowly
expelling blue smoke to announce the
gender of a baby burst into flames
the driver who jumped out of the vehicle
was convicted of dangerous operation of
a car Australians dude I'll get an idea
let's put blue smoke in the exhaust well
don't you think this may be a little bit
of a dangerous operation yeah it doesn't
matter though right because if I can put
it in there then the blue smoke will
come out of the back of the [ __ ]
thing everyone will be like it's a boy
right then I'll be [ __ ] all exciting
is it worth it though
well yeah it's worth it right because
they'll be like it's a boy and then I'll
pull over and they'll be like oh my god
yeah and we'll all get like a hug you
know gonna be little the blue smoke
around but great for Instagram yeah well
what if the cat catches fire it's not
gonna catch fire might is [ __ ] cool
for a jump air it's a boy for [ __ ]
sake I'll just tell you it's a [ __ ]
boy open up
goddammit tacking around I you know they
were in one of those [ __ ] [ __ ]
cars that are like half trucks have cars
get out get out it's a boy I'll just
tell you get out it's blue smart you can
say get the [ __ ] out of the cab get it
dude just don't do a gender-reveal looks
[ __ ] thing just say hey it's a boy or
get a [ __ ] thing and be like there's
is a boy look that I got a boy thing
here's a here's a onesie I just
anything for Instagram is so so stupid
how about the [ __ ] balloon that flew
away and the guy was so [ __ ] trying to
[ __ ] dude the blue the balloon [ __ ]
flew away
and he was like they were trying to bat
it and it [ __ ] flew away and the guy
tried to grab and he fell over the fence
trying to get it hey guy let it go just
say boy hey dude
don't die just let it go turn to your
wife and say boy these companies dude
that [ __ ] do it all together and
they're like we know the gender and we
put it in the cake eat the cake and they
slice the cake and it's pink it's like
such a [ __ ] why are you making it
harder to have a baby hey having a
baby's already real hard gender-reveal
goes hilariously wrong watched till the
end here's the other thing two videos
are always one minute long and it says
watch to the end dude I got the time man
it's one minute long oh wow this guy's
hilarious this guy looks like you would
play [ __ ] baseball in 1998 look at
him wow dude he fancies himself an
athlete look he tries to run he tries to
jump defense and [ __ ] falls and all
the kids are running after it
Wow dude man don't do gender anything
for Instagram don't do those things
that's the thing everything became such
a show now